en la universidad están los que van a
descubrir la cura para el cáncer
todavía hay una cosa que no nos cuadra y
es que estamos enseñando a los
profesionales del futuro con técnicas y
metodologías del pasado del siglo 20
incluso de siglos anteriores a mí me
gustaría que analizaremos un poco la
experiencia nos da notas y con eso
hacemos libros en el psir 21 la
experiencia mezclada con tecnología
queda queda todavía no tenemos soportes
ni contenidos adecuados para que
nuestros estudiantes para nosotros
mismos poder aprender de una forma
rápida de una forma inteligible de una
forma que sea más rápida y que reduzca
la curva de olvido
pero dejadme decir una cosa es que la
tecnología per se no aporta nada
muchos hemos visto clases llenas de
ordenadores yo mismo como profesor las
veo cada semana pero es decir que no es
la tecnología sino los contenidos y los
profesores es decir el contenido el
profesor y la comunidad de estudiantes
serán los que van a trabajar mejor en el
futuro
os presento una imagen
que fue una imagen revolucionaria en su
día
esta es la mano de berta de berta rongen
esposa de william wrong en un físico que
en 1901 recibió el premio nobel de
física y lo recibió porque descubrió los
rayos x esta es la primera vez que
veíamos el cuerpo humano por dentro
sorprendente hasta entonces hasta
entonces y mucho después nuestros
estudiantes de ciencias de la salud
estudian la medicina nos estudian a
nosotros estudian la anatomía como con
esquemas
y con muertos pero no con vivos
esto esto que os voy a enseñar es un
cáncer donde vemos a un linfocito t
atacando una célula cancerígena y donde
esta célula cancerígena muere tiene una
dosis
verdad que una imagen vale una imagen
importa inclusive como profesor cuando
pregunto a alguien si lo ha entendido
sabéis que me responde sí sí ahora lo
veo es brutal la dimensión que tienen
las imágenes para todos nosotros
y es por eso que un premio nobel de
dianas proteicas para terapias para el
cáncer inmunoterapia concretamente
pues dejadme que vea cómo estamos hoy 14
millones de personas cada año son
diagnosticadas con cáncer dramático
de estas de éstas
8 millones van a morir
todavía uno de los retos más importantes
es cómo vamos a formar
como vamos a formar a los oncólogos del
futuro con qué
nosotros tenemos una propuesta una
propuesta inspiradora una propuesta que
nos llena de ilusión porque la hemos
tratado la hemos trabajado durante años
con rigor científico contrastado con las
mejores universidades y hoy he deciros
que se está usando y se está usando con
éxito
qué es éxito es complicado mírate en el
mundo de la información la información
médico científica se dobla cada 18 meses
eso significa que en cinco años dos
tercios de toda la información
científica
no existirá hoy o sea no existe hoy
todavía imaginaros el nivel de capacidad
que hemos de tener todos para ir
formando nos en formación continua
pero en formación dejadme que os ponga
una pregunta una pregunta qué
para mí va a ser ilustrativa cuántos de
vosotros tenéis una carrera
muchas manos muchísimas manos algunos
con máster incluso
mirad si habéis hecho una carrera habéis
pasado 10.000 horas en una clase 10.000
horas en estas en este tipo de clases
cuántos de vosotros habéis disfrutado en
estas clases o qué pocas manos algunas
algunas si nos contéis el disfrute por
favor de vías en las últimas filas
mirad
10.000 horas es muy difícil de soportar
y sobre todo en un formato que recuerda
al del siglo pasado y del siglo del
siglo pasado porque no podemos cambiar
esto hoy en día la ubicuidad tecnológica
nos permite cambiar nos permite aportar
y eso es lo que pretendemos hacer
mirad cuántos nos hubiera gustado tener
el botón de adelante atrás o pausa o el
que me gustaba a mí el de deshacer black
en la clase ya lo decía lo decía mark
twain sabéis como definía mac mark twain
o no en una universidad decía es el
sitio donde los apuntes del profesor
pasan directamente a los apuntes del
alumno sin pasar por el cerebro ninguno
de los dos
no es eso lo que queremos verdad no es
eso lo que queremos para nuestros
médicos para nuestros científicos para
nuestros ingenieros
nosotros queremos un mundo en el cual
todo esté interconectado
hemos de ser capaces de juntar todas las
categorías todas las disciplinas para
que se expliquen unas a otras
ser capaces de crear itinerarios nuevos
donde la ingeniería se mezcle con la
medicina la química la bioquímica la
bioingeniería todo esté interconectado
solo así con nuevos itinerarios
conseguiremos
a aumentar el valor de la educación
porque dejadme decir que os digo una
cosa la
e innovación
no la hacen en un laboratorio no la hace
en una habitación divertida de llena de
colores no la hacen una gente con la
gorra del revés que va en skateboard la
innovación la hacemos todos en el siglo
21 la innovación viene dada por la
comunidad de hecho de los últimos
eventos e inventos que estáis utilizando
es la comunidad a la que marca y eso hay
que tenerlo en cuenta a la hora de
diseñar productos para la educación
esto que os presento ahora es un método
de trabajo sencillo donde tomamos la
realidad microscopio electrónico y
construimos que un personaje construimos
una modelización computacional de un
macrófago y lo hacemos trabajar lo
hacemos mover
esto es realmente no es futuro es
realidad hoy se está estudiando así en
diferentes universidades colaboramos
estrechamente con la harvard medical
school y con el mighty para que en este
caso nos test en los productos y además
los utilicen en sus clases cosa que les
puedo decir que el curso pasado ya
fueron utilizados con gran éxito
y que fue utilizado pues mirad desde
desde la visión de un tejido poder
explicar la visión de un tejido
vascularizado cómo podemos ir hacia
adentro cruzando membrana celular
llegando a citoplasma llegando a ver el
núcleo entrar por un poro del núcleo
llegará al adn que es lo más importante
en este caso porque es el código y ver
qué es lo que ocurre y vemos que aquí se
ha roto el adn esta proteína láctea
checados
es la que controla si se ha roto o no se
ha roto si se ha roto evita que a través
de una cascada proteica que se replique
y lo que lo determina es una serie de
proteínas que encontraremos como pues
analizándolo y qué proteína
encontraremos esta que veis aquí
coloreada
queremos enseñar mejor queremos utilizar
la tecnología para llegar a la
profundidad y la comprensión de procesos
complejos biológicos y conseguir
que en un futuro los profesionales estén
más formados más interconectados entre
ellos
mirad
cómo se evalúa todo esto tenemos que
jugar tenemos que jugar con qué pues con
lo que nos da la tecnología poder
ordenar procesos poder llegar a que a
mostrar comunidad poder compararme con
otros poder llegar a explicar lo que el
playstation me ha hecho desde que era
pequeño y es quiero jugar con otros
quiero compararme con otros y lo más
importante no quiero exámenes
un examen normalmente te dice pasa no
pasa fail
qué dice la playstation que os dicen los
juegos
game of pero sigue jugando prueba otra
vez la próxima vez mejorarás prueba otra
vez es decir cuántas veces en un examen
al terminar nos hubiera gustado decir a
higuain y volver a hacer
a mí
hoy en día los sistemas lo permiten hoy
en día los sistemas junto con profesores
con comunidad de estudiantes permite que
no solo de hacer esto sino crear
contenidos crear nuevos itinerarios
no solo nuevos itinerarios se van a
crear sino que ya estamos trabajando hoy
en simulaciones simulaciones de que de
entornos aquí tenéis membrana aquí
tenéis núcleo es decir puedo incluso
configurar el adn puedo llegar a hacer
eso les garantizo que en un futuro
nuestros hijos lo podrán hacer
porque el futuro es de los jóvenes pero
el presente lo tenemos que trabajar
nosotros y en el presente ya estamos
trabajando hoy en nuevos modelos en
nuevos modelos que puedan llegar a
captar la realidad de cada uno de
nosotros crear modelos computacionales y
poder conseguir en este caso un corazón
real
modelos computacionales que permitan
prevenir la enfermedad que hagan que
entre todos hagamos un futuro que sea
más sano más bueno para todos y que
todos podamos colaborar a él muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]